i swear to you i swear i know it's this
is going to seem like a lie i had no
intention of playing that character when
i wrote it hey hitler you're going to be
the best i'll you can do it look at me
i'm a brown supermodel
okay it doesn't make any sense
thor ragnarok
well with thor i wanted to do something
that felt different to the other films
you know i wanted to do a good job you
know i it's the first time that i'd
worked on someone else's ip really and
it was it's thor i think it was like the
17th movie they'd made and that had
nothing but consecutive hits the entire
time so it's no my job is not to come in
and say i think this is how you guys
need to be doing it my job is to come in
and go what's the best i can do to help
you
make thor the best that he can be and i
didn't think that all of chris's talents
had been utilized up until that point i
didn't think that the character was as
interesting as it could be because
looking at the comics it's proper it's
crazy it's cosmic you know there's so
many things that i had not seen in the
first two films and wanted to explore
obviously the jack kirby art and all of
that and even down to characters which
is a nice segue into my character korg
allow me to introduce myself my name is
cork i'm kind of like the leader in here
made of rocks as you can see but don't
let that intimidate you you don't need
to be afraid unless you're made of
scissors
just a little rock paper scissor joke
for you i just like the idea of playing
this big rock guy who was thor's buddy
he's like a sidekick oh i really wish i
had my hammer
emma quite unique was made from this
special metal from the heart of a dying
style and when i spun it really really
fast it gave me the ability to fly you
wrote a hammer
no i i didn't ride the hammer the hammer
are you on your back no no i i used to
spin it really fast and it would it
would pull me off oh my god emma pulled
you off the ground it would pull me off
the ground up into the air and i would
fly there's different types of the new
zealand accent you know and i based that
on the polynesian accent of like mainly
i was thinking about bouncers outside
nightclubs you know growing up in new
zealand and always like this massive
giant guys but they're the most
beautiful humble nice people you'll ever
meet you know and like they're also why
do they need to be aggressive they just
don't need to it's like a wall of a
person stopping you getting in so why
not be nice if you're that big you know
so you know i've grown up around a lot
of those guys and it's just like a it's
like a just a voice and a style and
there's just a sensibility that i've
always found really like
comforting to be around just being
polynesian as well i just like the idea
of having a character like that in an
american studio film i wasn't even sure
if people would even understand my
accent i thought well maybe they'll
probably make me revoice this or get
someone else to do it because you know
the voice is so over the top who the
hell is going to understand this but
it's been amazing the fact that people
can understand and also being grew to
love that character the damage is not
too bad
as long as the foundations are still
strong we can rebuild this place
it will become a haven for all peoples
and aliens of the universe
now those foundations are gone sorry
thor love and thunder
core is back in love and thunder again
it's me
how would i not crowbar myself in there
you know i think it would have been a
disservice i couldn't believe i'm
talking like this about myself i do
think it would have been a disservice to
the fans to not include
korg from this film i thought that you
know my life was complete when i worked
with cate blanchett and that was
one of the great experiences of my
career and then coming in to to this new
film we've got russell crowe
christian bale natalie portman you know
natalie is someone i've admired for many
years and i've always found her very
funny in person and i've always liked
enjoyed watching her work i just was
always wanted to work with her and when
the opportunity came to bring jane
foster back to the franchise i jumped at
that and also just to focus on the
mighty thor the comic run by jason aaron
where
she gets to pick up the hammer and
becomes a superhero and what's cooler
there's nothing cool of a character like
jane foster to then transform and evolve
and become like you know become a
massive part of the of the story and
then christian bale who you know look
listen but personally between christian
and russell like you know there's
probably two of my favorite actors let's
see who you are i take off your disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
i get a chance to work with both of them
they're two of my heroes and to work
with both of them in the same film it
was just something else you know i've
adored russell for many years you know i
think i've watched mastering commander
probably 70 times russ was one of those
those guys who you know you're in good
hands with him when you're watching one
of his films you know you're getting
looked after it's like yeah it's like
there's very few people who are real
stars like that and i've always felt
that about him and then became friends
with him in real life you're in great
hands as well he's a great dude
jojo rabbit
so caging skies was the book that jojo
rabbit is
loosely based on my mother had just read
it she gave me the book she said read
this book i think it would make a great
film but the way she described it is
actually
more like jojo rabbit because i read the
book and it was nothing like the film
that i it was like
very dark you know there's like a lot of
really intense sad moments and it gets
pretty twisted um it's more of a kind of
psychological thriller than anything and
there was no comedy it wasn't
it wasn't a comedy there was no
imaginary hitler so all of that stuff i
put in later on and i was trying to
think of like how can i make this my own
how can i make this more of a tiger film
the heart of the book and what made it
really special and what drew me in was
this relationship between the boy and a
girl that's being hidden by his mother
in the house you know that really is the
heart of the whole film i wrote the
first few drafts and i was really happy
with the script then we started thinking
who would play this imaginary hitler now
this was about 2011
and we started sending it out to
different people i don't think a lot of
actors even got to look at the script
but basically i think a lot of agents
were like hell no am i sending this to
my client there's no
way in hell that i'm going to ruin my
client's career by making him play
hitler so i don't think
a lot of these people actually got to
see it and we were going to these actors
because
at the time you know to make a film like
this you know you needed a-listers you
needed like big names to be able to sell
these films what then happened is i went
off and i made what we do in the shadows
hunt for the world of people and thor i
met three other films and just left that
script on ice and by the time i came
back to it the whole cinematic landscape
had changed and you didn't need
a-listers to sell your film anymore you
actually just needed good films so
searchlight picked up the script and
said we want to make it under one
condition that you play hitler poor jojo
what's wrong little man
hi adolf want to tell me about that
rabbit incident what was all that about
they wanted me to kill it
i'm sorry
i couldn't don't worry about it i
couldn't care less but now they call me
a scared rabbit let them say whatever
they want people used to say a lot of
nasty things about me oh this guy's a
lunatic oh look at that psycho he's
gonna get us all killed
i swear to you i swear i know it's this
is gonna seem like a lie i had no
intention of playing that character when
i wrote it look at me
i'm a brown supermodel
okay it doesn't make any sense it
started what they said started to make
sense in that if you do get a massive
actor to play hitler in a small film
about two kids and you know them
overcoming their differences and
um and intolerance and trying to make a
beautiful film about love it the whole
thing gets overshadowed when you have
you know like a massive celebrity
playing hitler you know denzel
washington is hitler it's just not gonna
work mate do not let her put you in a
brain prison that dear jojo is one thing
that cannot and must not ever ever
happen to a german
do not let your german brain be bossed
around
i won't let her boss my german brain
around minefield try not to i did zero
to no
research about hitler i remember i
remember looking up books about hitler
on amazon i didn't want to spend the
money because i was just out of
principle i don't want to spend money on
this [ __ ] then i was like i don't
even want to read about him
i don't care about his life i don't care
about why he did things i didn't care
about what was behind the motives behind
anything i just didn't care about him i
also wanted to ridicule him i wanted to
lambast him you know even beyond the
grave i was hoping that you know he
somehow like you know his
spirit what's left of it that i could
somehow just humiliate him and piss him
off even more from the grave i created
the character based on just like ideas
of like goofy best friend characters
there's nothing from drop dead fred in
this but
you know that idea of this sort of like
or beetlejuice you know this idea of an
annoying best friend fantasy best friend
that a kid has it's got to feel a little
bit more in that vein where it's like
it's in this kid's head it can't be a
real depiction of hitler because you
know it's also it's untrue it wouldn't
be in a kid's fantasy idea of who
someone is it's a fantasy that would
never be exactly like the person
what we do in the shadows
the point is deacon that you have not
done the dishes for five years that this
love is right it's unacceptable to have
so many bloody dishes all over this
bench like this i'm so embarrassed when
people come over here what does it
matter you bring them over you kill them
jermaine and i i think started writing
this in around
2004 maybe we'd always intended to be in
the film we we shot a little short
version of this thing of what we did in
the shadows in 2005 and just to see like
what the characters would be like what
you know if we could sustain something
just even for 25 minutes with these
characters and whether it would still be
funny after 25 minutes and then um we
cut that together and sort of made this
little thing and yeah we realized yeah
we could probably like keep this idea
going for maybe an hour and a half if
we're lucky they haven't watched this
shower for about 20 years that is
something that needs to be done weekly
now i know i think you know it's just
hard for me because i used to be
yeah royalty for me to have to
i you know take the corpse out of the
dryer over like the next sort of six
years or so we just like every
couple of weeks a year we would just
like get back into it and just reopen up
the script jermaine and either way that
we work we end we would end up like
doing maybe a page a year and then we
ended up with 150 pages so it took 150
years to write the script like any real
smart filmmakers we didn't show anyone
we just improvised the whole film well
that didn't go so great
i hit the main artery
so yes a real mess in there um
on the upside i think she had a really
good time
viago i mean i think just costume wise
kind of got that mr darcy sort of like
there's a little bit of interview of the
vampire kind of going on there but in
terms of the character viagra is
basically
just a mixture of
c-3po and my mother just that anal
vampire who can't
stand mess and wants everything to be
structured and needs to have regimen and
it has to make a chore wheel so that
everyone can keep on top of doing the
dishes or vacuuming beacon on dishes and
it still hasn't moved in five years it
only issues like when you're a vampire
and you live
forever
you can always put things off to the
next day so why bother cleaning on a
monday when you can clean on a tuesday
10 years later we'll all do our jobs
starting with a certain deacon i will do
my dishes
i mean i always prefer to work with my
friends um on shadows it was jermaine
and i we surrounded ourselves with all
of our other friends you know including
stu
who
i went to high school with and jackie i
went to high school with i've known them
since i was about 12 or 13. yes she was
a flatmate of mine for years it's
actually the best way of working like
because you can give each other [ __ ] you
can like you know pick on each other and
it's more like working with your family
you don't have to
beat around the bush with stuff you can
just be honest and yeah they're the
people i trust the most when um asking
for feedback or you know when i go to
criticism i know that it's coming from a
place of love or the you know they
actually are concerned about something
in a scene or something so which is
often yeah if you don't know someone
you're a bit wary and also actors um are
insane
mandalorian
stop that
identify yourself
i am ig-11 i am this child's nurse droid
and require that you remind him to me
immediately a nurse droid i thought it
was a hunter aren't igs usually hunters
well evidently this one's a nurse ig-11
is a droid we don't say robot in the
star wars universe because that's not
appropriate
he's a droid and it's a bounty hunter
droid they're a bounty hunter droid
charged with in this particular yeah
when we meet um ig-11 charged with
finding grogu the baby
the baby it's not a baby yoda we just
gotta stop saying baby yoda it's not
baby yoda
i'm sorry nurse but
you're gonna have to get out of here
are you refusing my request
no
i'm telling you to get out of here
[Applause]
that was unpleasant i'm sorry you had to
see that
it's again my own accent i don't change
my accent whenever i act you might have
noticed why bother there are
way too many americans in the world
anyway
way too american actors so you guys you
guys you've got that covered with that
accent very few new zealanders that's
the point of difference i'm like a
special little
sweet little
thing that you find in the forest you
know what's this it's like a magical
little curiosity
that's my lane that's where i'm at and
i've got that covered you guys stick to
your your lead acting your lead role
rules you also directed an episode of
mandalorian what was it like for you to
sort of jump into the star wars universe
and play around in that kind of sandbox
there was a very special thing for me to
to do that mandalorian episode the first
day i think we were working with about
70 stormtroopers and a tie fighter yeah
i mean i have to say it was one of the
highlights of not only my career but my
life was to be walking around directing
stormtroopers and also to be um to be
able to work and be doing that episode
under the guidance of favreau who became
a friend and became someone who's been
very supportive of my work it was great
because it was his idea he'd written
everything and for me just to come in as
a director when i didn't write it wasn't
my concept it was really nice just to
kind of just come in and go like well
this is what i can offer you like how
can i like help with you know make
keeping the flow of all the other
episodes and and also what can i learn
whenever i work i want to learn
something from someone and i learned a
lot on that one
free guy
who could forget
2021's
hit film free guy in which i play
the character antoine who was
say kind of the bad guy good morning
people oh you are fired there is some
concern with the bloody zombies
retailers won't carry the game it's out
never even happened next it's your
lawyers they need to get your position
which lawsuit are we talking about
billy milly rusk no sweat that will
never see the inside of a courtroom
because she's got no proof and her ex
partner works for me he owns a giant
game company he's got it all he's got
the clothes the fashion he's got the
money again one of my favorite types of
characters he's a bit of an [ __ ] and
a bit of an idiot i love the idea of
playing
the ceo of this big company and also
having no idea what that meant and you
know i don't know anything about gaming
and again i was like should i do any
research into this world
it seems too hard
seems like there's too much to learn and
i don't my brain's full
so
i i didn't i just played what i thought
a character like that should be like and
i constructed play something i could
concentrate on like just the kind of
relatable human elements where it's like
someone who obviously was picked on his
entire life
and finally got some cash
and this pretty much tells it all
they're always going to be you know it's
like this just like you've got a chip on
your shoulder and you want to prove
things to people in there and some
people push it too far and they just
become
major dicks ips and seaquals that is the
thing that people want let me ask you a
question okay you love kentucky fried
chicken right no if you love kentucky
fried chicken and i made kentucky fried
chicken and i know that you love
kentucky fried chicken why would i make
another restaurant called i don't know
albuquerque boiled turkey okay makes no
sense homie what am i gonna give you a
sequel kentucky fried chicken chicken
part two i didn't mean to improvise that
much it's just whenever people laugh i
mean like i'm a sucker for that cool
we're a team hey would you come up with
a catch phrase all right okay on three
one two three get back to work i'll just
keep going until they're telling me to
stop but that was good those guys know
how to die shawn knows how to feed
someone who you know who's improvising
knows how to you know where which way to
direct them and a lot of people think
that improvising is just talking just
saying the first thing that comes to
your head and like but actually it's you
know you've got to be aware of what's
happening in the scene and where you're
trying to get the scene to go to and
you've got to be having a conversation
with someone most of improvising is
listening to the other person and just
reacting to that but a lot of people
want
they've got some jokes in their head
that they really want to say and they're
not listening to what you taught you
what you're saying they're just waiting
for their turn to tell the joke but
sean's good at like creating that
conversation in a scene where where the
improvising actually makes sense and
actually works and is usable which is
the main thing that you want
our flag means death
blackbeard is basically me with a fake
big beard and fake wig on and then all
these leather clothes
guess what accent i'm doing
blackbeard the original guy was from
bristol
in england you know what that sounds
like it sounds like steven merchant i
can't even get close to what they're
saying steve merchant he sounds a bit
like that
you imagine black beer sounding like
that i can't even do that accent and nor
do i want to spend my precious time
learning how to love one on blackbeard
huge fan sir huge
well that's lovely but you don't need to
say sir all right it's just blackbeard
yes sir blackbeard sir nice to meet you
hello hello nice to meet you hi how are
hey look i love all the rope everyone's
wearing rope everyone's grubby as well
filthy look at this bunch of wild
characters on the high seas what i found
out from the extensive research i did
which was typing in blackbeard into
wikipedia it says not much is known
about him so that's all i need to know
we're done we're done here i don't need
to
i don't need to be authentic there's no
one's going to pick on me for for
getting it wrong
no one knew anything about him they say
his name maybe have been edward teach
there are other names that were given to
him they say maybe he come from bristol
maybe he actually grew up in jamaica no
one knows anything about him so that's
open season on that character
i have to tell you so i could do
whatever i wanted he could have been
from new zealand no one [ __ ] knew it
was just more fun to be able to play him
as like you know kind of like a grumpy
version of me or like one of my uncles
growing up you know i've grown up around
a lot of black beards something about
that character as well that i i
appreciate in that it's about someone
who's been he's been doing something for
about
20 years he's got really good at it
everyone wants him to keep going
but he's just getting
slowly more progressively pissed off
with the industry
and
over it
if you were to show me the ways of an
aristocrat
i could probably show you a thing or two
about being a bloodthirsty
pirate wouldn't that be something
you serious so reece and i have worked
together we've known each other for i
mean over 20 years we've always worked
well together there's just a sort of
synchronicity and a connection between
our brains and the way that we
act or improvise where we always seem in
tune our flag means death
that was no different we came in and we
slotted into our roles and it was
interesting for us two old friends
playing two people who are in love you
know on the high seas in the 1700s oh
that's a lovely piece of silk you have
there
this teddy old thing
well sometimes the old things the best
things
my eye
there we
go look at that
you wear fine things well
it's just weird to kind of pretend that
you're romantically interested in your
old friend but then all the scenes that
we did together were my favorite ones
because we get we just got to play and
just you know
sit around and just play with words look
at that there's one two
nine guns all over him nine guns that's
two i have i have one gun and one knife
just like everyone else
so far i've played this you know
ridiculous effeminate vampire based on
my mum hitler
i've played my dad in the film i've
played a hot priest twice but they were
brothers
so it wasn't the same character
blackbeard
[ __ ] owner of a game
tech company droid so every single one
has been pretty different that makes me
happy because i just don't want to ever
feel like if i'm repeating myself too
much and even with my filmmaking i feel
like the charm or like the magic
started to go out of what i'm doing so
my decisions really are based on and
even when i'm making films like what's
going to keep me interested what makes
me feel nervous it's just about
continuing to keep myself interested and
i mean
the reason i really if one was getting
into any of this is so i could just play
different roles and do you know and just
play around